you know the easiest thing
about doing this show is the answers are
always the same
you guys riding around in your car you
already know what i'm going to say
if you've listened to this show for six
months you know what i'm going to say
when somebody calls in
and why are the answers always the same
because they're not based on
nuanced concepts they're based on
principles
principle is the law of gravity will
cause your butt to hit the sidewalk if
you jump off a building
that's a principle well i sort of got
these cool wing things i want to try
yeah but there's always the law of
gravity
there are principles like we don't
borrow money that's a principle the
borrower's slave of the lender
we always have a plan don't build a
tower without first counting the cost
always live on less than you make
because a foolish man devours all he has
these are principles always be
outlandishly outrageously generous
because generous people are unbelievably
attractive
they're the best people on the planet
and you get to choose to be one today
ready set go
these are principles another principle
is what barbara bush said a thousand
years ago and i've been given credit for
it lately but i wish i had said it i
just stole it from her
what happens in your house is a whole
lot more important than what happens in
the white house
if you're waiting on washington to fix
your life dave ramsey adds to that
you're stupid because washington can't
even fix itself
it's the island of misfit toys and
you're waiting on the democrats to fix
your life
you're waiting on the republicans to fix
your life
the only shot you've got to fix in your
life is you fixing it
and so when covet hits and the world
comes to a freaking screeching halt
because we're all going to die from the
pandemic hardly anyone
did statistically the survival rate by
the way for all age groups
is north of 99
for all age groups just in case you
haven't looked at the cdc site lately
doesn't mean you can get sick said
survival rate
but we shut the whole world down
and so we needed the government to help
us i'm from the government and i'm here
to help is a phrase that should cause
you to be
terrified and they came out with the ppp
loans you remember the ppp
loans we're going to give businesses
these loans because we told these
businesses that they had to shut down
because the whole world is going to
freaking die and if you go to a
restaurant you're going to kill your
mother
and so you must die at home
and we shut the whole economy down and
everyone's at home sucking their thumb
in abject fear
and poverty sets in and the government
comes riding in
on a white horse and says we're going to
give you free money oh wait it's a loan
but it's not really a loan it'll be a
grant because we're going to forgive it
as long as you maintain your payroll
i got death threats from some of you
morons because i told no one to take out
these ppp loans
stay away from it it's a trap don't step
up on the door they're going to pull the
lever you churches are
idiots for taking out a loan from the
government
as if they're not going to come in and
interfere and tell you how to operate
and violate your freedom of religion
because oh it's not alone dave it's a
grant you're just so naive and you're
such a fanatic and you never borrow
money
and this is the worst times these are
unprecedented times we have to pivot
remember unprecedented in pivot two
words that we just wore the crap
out in april you remember these i heard
them over and over and over and over and
over again i'm
on here screaming all the ramsey
personalities are on all of our
media events screaming do not take out
the ppp loan
from politico today when the government
pledged to give small business billions
of dollars in rescue loans during the
pandemic
it was all for almost too good to refuse
the loans should be forgiven if
employers
only maintain payroll in little more
than four months the paycheck protection
plan the ppp doled out
525 billion dollars to 5.2
million borrowers lenders that help the
government deliver the money are warning
that the effort is running into
new delays well there you go here's this
one check this out
the banks say the process is for
converting the government-backed loans
into grants has been frustrating and has
not happened
at all a lack of communication from the
small business administration
now i'm shocked and the treasury
department you mean government doesn't
communicate
which have run the uh which have run the
effort since congress created it
in march banks which have loaned their
own money with the expectation
that it would be repaid by the
government have been submitting
applications for loan forgiveness to the
sba since august the 10th
but the lenders say the agency has been
silent on it whether any of the
applications will be accepted
to date the spa said thursday it has
received 96
000 forgiveness applications
representing
fewer than 2 percent of the total loans
but has not
approved one
not one loan has been forgiven out of
ninety
six thousand applications and that's
only
two percent of them
no bank i know anywhere in the country
has received any money from the sba said
brad bolton president ceo of
community spirit bank in alabama the
warnings from lenders are raising new
doubts about the
implementation of the small business
rescue effort well no crap
which was seen by many as a success not
by me
its authority to issue new loans expired
on august 8th thank you jesus
and there is a broad broad bipartisan
support to relaunch the program if
lawmakers can strike a deal on economic
relief you've got to be kidding
you idiots are going to do it again the
confusion is creating potential
headwinds for small businesses
as they struggle to emerge from a
recession and their loans that were
supposed to be forgiven
have not been adding to the frustration
is a growing list of unresolved
questions from banks about how to handle
the
forgiveness applications banks say
they've gotten conflicting information
from various sba officials
the sba people if you don't know is the
dmv of the federal government for small
business
completely freaking incompetent cannot
find their butt with both hands
and they've been given this task to run
this thing and they cannot do it
they don't have the capacity
intellectually they don't have the
capacity
process and systems wise they're
complete freaking nincompoops
and you got 525
billion dollars laying on their desk
that's gonna go from
not being forgiven to being alone
with your local bank they've pretty much
been radio silent over the last few
weeks said the consumer bankers
association general counsel
there's still plenty of technical issues
banks have as we push the sba to offer
some guidance they can't find their way
to work don't look for guidance from
them
the situation echoes problems that
plagued the program at its start
when the trump administration rushed to
launch the lending vehicle
but left banks and businesses in the
dark about key details
there's this ridiculous entitlement bs
that our culture has developed
that says when we're in a crisis the
government has to rush in and fix our
lives
and everyone was yelling fix our lives
fix our lives so we threw money at it
and no guidelines and no systems and no
processes
and the loans aren't going to be
forgiven because of incompetence
and i'm gonna sit here and say it i'm
sorry i told you so
i told you not to take the money
i told you over and over not to take the
money two of you threatened to burn my
house down
but i told you not to take the money
it's a principle
the government is not here to help you
they're a parasite
they're a tick on your butt this is the
dave ramsey show